the only thing I'm a little skeptical  with is  you know when they try to  make a game bigger than it actually is  I'm concerned with a little bit of fluff  on Starfield uh especially the same  terms like a thousand plans to think for  the most part those thousand planets  they don't ever intend on you going to  those planets it's just something like  kind of an adventure thing so I think  that's mainly what it is uh when they  say they've they've you know they've  crafted some of the planets I think  right there you're looking at okay here  we have all these Brazilia generated  stuff that you can get materials from  you could kill people you can get  equipment from but these planets is  where the actual story is going to be  and the missions are that's what I told  Daddy I think the same thing yeah  because remember like even Mass Effect  one song Yeah remember there was certain  plans that you and then you unlock a  mission